grünes licht für astrazeneca die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde
empfiehlt den impfstoff ohne
einschränkung gutachten zum sexuellen
missbrauch im erzbistum köln kardinal
woelki wird entlastet aber mehr als 200
personen werden beschuldigt schulen auch
schulen zu wie corona zeit belastet
kinder schwer
jetzt wird über förderprogramme
diskutiert
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport
gibt es nachher mit norbert lehmann
eingebunden so formiert und diese
nachricht war heute mit besonderer
spannung erwartet worden vor knapp zwei
stunden kam sie aus amsterdam
astrazeneca darf weiter geimpft werden
und zwar ohne jegliche einschränkungen
das entschied nach der whu gestern nun
auch die europäische arzneimittelbehörde
ema die impfung sei sicher und wirksam
in europa haben 18 länder ihre impfungen
mit astrazeneca ganz oder teilweise
eingestellt
deutschland hatte seit der zweiten
februarwoche insgesamt fast 1,8
millionen dosen des britisch
schwedischen vakzins gespritzt
durchschnittlich rund 50.000 dosen
täglich impfungen die seite im stopp am
montag aus vielen andrea maurer über das
was aus der entscheidung der eu behörde
folgt als die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema heute ihre
risikobewertung verkündet geht es um
nicht weniger als die zukunft eines
dringend gebrauchten impfstoffes
wir sind zu einer klaren
wissenschaftlichen einschätzung gekommen
dass ist ein sicherer und wirksamer
impfstoff
das was wir gerade sehen ist eine
situation die zu erwarten war
wenn sie millionen menschen impfen ist
es unvermeidbar dass seltene oder
ernsthafte zwischenfälle und
erkrankungen unmittelbar nach der
impfung auftreten
der impfstoff solle schnell wieder
verkauft werden allerdings mit
warnhinweis auf seltene fälle von
blutgerinnseln so die iaea kurz nach der
entscheidung will eigentlich der
gesundheitsminister vor die presse
treten
der termin wird verschoben der beschluss
lägen nicht vor heißt es
erleichterung und sorge unterdessen in
deutschen impfzentren wie hier in
trostberg bayern erleichterung weil sie
astrazeneca wieder für impfen können
aber auch sorge weil niemand weiß wie
schnell die verzögerung durch den
impfstoff behoben sind
wir würden versuchen die 1200 termine
die wir seit montag abgesagt
wieder sofort einzubestellen mit
gewissen schwierigkeiten dass die leute
natürlich unter umständen jetzt im
moment nicht erreichbar sind und dass
natürlich der impfstoff jetzt wieder
einen gewissen vertrauensschwund hat
drei tage lang lag astrazeneca nach dem
impfstoff sprichwörtlich auf eis in den
kühlschränken der impfärzte politisch
wird es nun vor allem darum gehen den
image schaden zu begrenzen
ich habe mir aber trotzdem sorgen in via
astra ziehen die kalorien deswegen so
viel wie möglich über die hausärzte zu
verhelfen
wenn der hausarzt ist der mediator für
die akzeptanz an der stelle der kann
auch am besten einschätzen ob derjenige
patient gut geeignet schlecht geeignet
immer lauter werden auch die stimmen die
auf eine schnelle zulassung und
bestellung des russischen impfstoffs
publik wie drängen der seit zum teil
besser als bereits zugelassene
impfstoffe sagt markus söder heute eine
klare impfstrategie die wird beim
virtuellen impf gipfel im kanzleramt
morgen dringend gesucht ja spannender
tag auch für berlin schock und energy
da müsste die entscheidung der ema doch
für freude sorgen wird nun sofort weiter
geimpft also sofort nicht da steht noch
der beschluss hier in deutschland aus
denn sparen und die gesundheitsminister
der bundesländer müssen sich noch über
die entscheidung der ema beugen und das
wollen sie heute abend noch tun so hören
wir dass das deutschland aber auch
darauf hin dass es möglichst schnell
wieder weiter gehen soll und wir hören
auch das ist wahrscheinlich dann mit
einem warnhinweis weitergeht für
besonders betroffene risikogruppen aber
das hoffen wir jetzt im laufe des abends
zu erfahren
dann könnte vip morgen geplant der
virtuelle impfgipfel auch darüber
beschließen
wie das ganze an die hausärzte verteilt
wird das schreckgespenst das astra
zeneca dann komplett ausfällt für die
impfstrategie das ist damit weg wie es
um das vertrauen bestellt ist ist damit
noch nicht gesagt und es ändert auch
nichts an der zweiten debatte die hier
ja gerade tobt nämlich die frage wie
geht man jetzt mit weiteren öffnungs
schritten um da wollen ja bund und
länder am montag darüber beraten und
entscheiden und da gibt es ja auch
wieder alles in verschiedene richtungen
die einen sagen wir nehmen auf keinen
fall öffnungs schritte zurück
die anderen sagen doch wir brauchen eine
harte notbremse da hilft jetzt diese
entscheidung leider erstmal überhaupt
nicht weiter ja und ein anderes thema
dürfte dem gesundheitsminister auch
weniger freude machen da geht es um den
vorwurf er habe den apotheken bei der
verteilung von masken viel zu viel geld
bezahlt wie sieht es damit aus
ja dazu konnten wir ihnen noch nicht
persönlich und öffentlich fragen weil
jetzt die pressekonferenz verschoben
worden ist aber das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hat sich
schon geäußert und man merkt dass es
nicht mehr alleine sozusagen die
drescher abbekommen möchte für einen
neuen vorwurf ist verweist darauf dass
diese entscheidung jetzt gefallen ist
nachdem die bundesländer sich darüber
verständigt haben und dass außerdem der
finanzminister damit entschieden hat das
gesundheitsministerium bekommt er
rückendeckung vom haushaltspolitischen
sprecher der cdu der sagte heute unter
schäuble wäre so etwas gar nicht
passiert und implizierte dass olaf
scholz eben das geld zu locker sitzen
hat also da merkt man dass hier jetzt
langsam eine abwehrschlacht gegen die
anhaltende kritik an gesundheitsminister
ist sich entwickelt aber sie ist
natürlich im raum und die sorge das hat
die opposition heute noch mal geäußert
ist groß dass sich ähnliches bei den
schnelltests die ihr auch kostenlos zur
verfügung gestellt werden wiederholt
vielen dank und energy nach berlin
wie es jetzt mit der impfkampagne in
deutschland weitergeht mehr
informationen hierzu sehen sie gleich in
einem zdf spezial direkt nach dieser
sendung und in unserer app fragen und
antworten zu den impfstoffen von den
komplikationen bis zur wirksamkeit auch
in dieser sendung haben wir noch mehr
zur corona krise aber zunächst schauen
wir auf die katholische kirche und ihre
aufarbeitung von missbrauchsfällen im
erzbistum köln wurde heute ein lang
erwartetes gutachten dazu vorgestellt
es ist bereits das zweite das erste hat
der erzbischof woelki mit hinweis auf
mängel unter verschluss gehalten
202 beschuldigte liste das gutachten auf
zwei hochrangige geistliche entband
woelki umgehend von ihren aufgaben
andrea bögge berichtet 900 seiten mit
brisantem inhalt das gutachten über den
umgang der kölner bistum spitze mit
missbrauchsfällen
präsentiert von strafrecht klavier und
gehrke heute in köln das ergebnis
höchste verantwortungsträger haben diese
taten nicht nach oben gemeldet und sie
haben damit untersuchungen
augenscheinlich untersuchungen und
strafverfahren verhindert sie haben
nicht sanktioniert sondern verzögert
rund 200 beschuldigte und 300
betroffenen 40 jahren nennt die studie
unter den klerikern die mit fällen von
missbrauch nicht ordnungsgemäß
umgegangen sein sollen sind prominente
namen wie etwa der verstorbene kardinal
joachim meisner herr doktor meister
trifft mithin allein rund ein drittel
aller von uns festgestellten
pflichtverletzung stark belastet das
gutachten auch den jetzigen hamburger
erzbischof hieße der 54 jährige der
lange personalverantwortung im kölner
erzbistum hatte bot am nachmittag seinen
rücktritt an
um schaden vom amt des erzbischofs sowie
vom erzbistum hamburg abzuwenden biete
ich papst franziskus meinen amtsverzicht
an
und bitte ihn um die sofortige
entbindung von seinen aufgaben
zwei weitere kleriker weihbischof
dominikus schwaderlapp und kirchen
richtigen tasten macher wurden von
kardinal woelki vorläufig suspendiert
auch schwaderlapp bot daraufhin seinen
rücktritt an
ein anfang aber um zukünftig vertuschung
zu verhindern wohl nicht genug
es war mit sicherheit ein erster großer
schritt der jetzt gegangen wurde aber es
müssen viele weitere folgen um dieses
phänomen missbrauch umfassend
aufzuarbeiten
auch aus theologischer perspektive
historischer perspektive um eben genau
zu sehen wo liegen auch strukturelle
ursachen die missbrauch in der
katholischen kirche begünstigen auch den
erwartungen von betroffenen die
sexualisierte gewalt durch priester
erlitten haben genügt die heutige
juristische aufarbeitung nicht
ich bin enttäuscht dass es keine
moralisch ethische bewertung gibt ich
bin enttäuscht nach wie vor dass keiner
dieser männer im vorfeld zu seiner
schuld gestanden habe und was die alle
erst es schwarz auf weiß brauchten was
sie falsch gemacht haben
das gutachten heute eines dass die
katholische kirche in deutschland wohl
erschüttert wie ein düsseldorf spreche
ich jetzt mit dauerte ferber dort die
ersten konsequenzen nach dem gutachten
haben wir gerade gehört wie geht es denn
nun weiter ja alle blicke richten sich
jetzt erst mal nach rom wir haben es ja
gehört erzbischofs und auch weihbischof
schwaderlapp haben den papst gebeten zu
prüfen ob sie eben ihre ämter zurück
geben sollen aber es geht längst nicht
nur um personelle konsequenzen
wichtig sind vor allen dingen auch die
strukturellen reformen
da haben die gutachter heute auch
wichtige hinweise gegeben beispielsweise
dass akten personalakten ordentlich
geführt werden müssten
dass beispielsweise eine hotline für
anonyme tippgeber eingerichtet werden
könnte oder auch dass die bistümer ihren
informationsaustausch verbessern müssten
denn wenn ein täter den ort wechselt
erfahren dass andere oftmals gar nicht
all das das fehlte ja und das hat laut
der gutachter auch den die vertuschung
von missbrauch systematisch begünstigt
die gutachter haben zudem betont dass
sie nur eine juristische prüfung
vorgenommen hätten also dass das große
bild noch fehle
und da ist es eben so dass vor der
kirche jetzt jede menge
aufklärungsarbeit noch liegt und die
betrifft nicht nur das erzbistum köln
auch da gab es bereits hinweise im
gutachten dass es auch möglicherweise in
anderen bistümern
zur vertuschung gekommen sei all das
steht jetzt vermutlich unter großem
zeitdruck denn die kirchenaustritte die
sprechen eine deutliche sprache
die einschätzung von dort bewerber
vielen dank dafür nach düsseldorf es
hatte sich schon angedeutet jetzt steht
fest die renten werden in diesem jahr in
westdeutschland nicht erhöht wegen der
korona krise in ostdeutschland gibt es
ein kleines plus von 0,72 prozent
ob renten angehoben werden oder nicht
hängt maßgeblich davon ab wie sich die
löhne entwickelt haben und diesen 2020
im westen um mehr als zwei prozent
gesunken
ein jahr corona krise für schülerinnen
und schüler eltern und lehrkräfte heißt
dass ein jahr lang eigentlich nie zu
wissen wie es langfristig weitergeht
gerade berät die kultusministerkonferenz
darüber wie man kinder und jugendliche
besser durch diese schwierige zeit
lotsen kann mit speziellen
förderprogrammen zum beispiel auch die
technische ausstattung der schulen ist
ein thema doch es braucht noch mehr
nicola albrecht berichtet aus
brandenburg eine interaktive schultafeln
gute netzanbindung und technische
ausstattung machen am staatlichen
gymnasium in bad belzig das möglich was
vielerorts immer noch nicht geht
alle schüler werden nun gleichzeitig
unterrichtet in der schule und zu hause
schulleiterin katrin winzig fordert von
den bildungsministern dass das endlich
bundesweit standard wird das ist nicht
daran hängen dafür auf dem schulträger
geld oder nicht geld hat wie gut seine
schule ausgestattet ist über solche
fragen sollten sie sich mal überlegen
denn das hat corona gezeigt diese großen
unterschiede haben kinder bevorzugt oder
benachteiligt
doch egal wie gut die ausstattung auch
ist lern lücken sind wohl bei allen
entstanden und im vielstimmigen konzert
der bundesländer fehlt auch
diesbezüglich eine einheitliche
strategie samstags unterricht verkürzte
ferien gratis nachhilfe viele vorschläge
stehen im raum
eltern fordern vor allem ein
nachhaltiges konzept keine zusätzliche
belastung wir halten auch von so
kurzfristigen lösungen wie ferien
verkürzen oder als schuljahr verlängern
oder wochenend unterricht da hatten wir
relativ wenig davon wir brauchen
langfristige maßnahme um zu gucken was
jetzt in den in diesem jahr zu kurz
gekommen ist was war da in den nächsten
zwei bis drei jahren aufholen können das
wird ein marathon ist kein
kurzstreckenlauf aus berlin kommt der
vorschlag dass im zweifel die eltern
entscheiden ihre kinder die klassenstufe
wiederholen zu lassen
keine gute idee findet bildungsforscher
kai maaz neben individueller förderung
braucht es jetzt vor allem eins mehr
flexibilität im system
wir wissen aus der forschung dass das
wiederholen einer klassenstufe eine sehr
effektive form ist und mit lern
rückständen umzugehen eine möglichkeit
um lärm rückstände aufzuholen bestünde
möglicherweise darin die lernziele nicht
mehr zwingend an ein schuljahr zu
koppeln
die abiturienten betrifft das nicht mehr
sie wollen nur noch gut durch die
prüfungen kommen schauen wir auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen für deutschland
sie steigen weiter deutlich
und das obwohl daten aus hamburg heute
fehlen dem robert koch institut wurden
innerhalb von 24 stunden 17 1504
neuinfektionen gemeldet 3148 mehr als
vergangenen donnerstag 227 menschen
starben in verbindung mit coop 19
und auch die bundesweite incident steigt
weiter und liegt jetzt wieder knapp über
90 bergamo in italien vor rund einem
jahr war die stadt das epizentrum
bewährungs krise in europa nirgendwo
sonst sterben seiner zeit so viele
menschen an oder mit kogit 19
die bilder der militärkonvois gingen um
die welt mit lastwagen vor die armee die
toten aus der stadt weil die krematorien
überfüllt fahren ganz italien erinnerte
heute an dem mehr als 100000 pandemie
opfer
andreas postel berichtet der sarg mit
ihrem vater war auf einem dieser
militärlastwagen und dieser nacht in
bergamo verstorben im zusammenhang mit
coop 19 verabschieden konnte sich
rosella fina sie nicht von ihm
wir haben ihnen diese militärkonvoi
wegbringen sehen ohne dessen
bestimmungsort zu kennen und dann haben
wir später erfahren dass mein vater in
venedig eingeäschert wurde
rosell als vater war einer von hundert
3432 opfern die italien seit ausbruch
der pandemie zu beklagen hat in bergamo
wird nun ein jahr später mit einer
baumpflanzung der sogenannte wald des
erinnerns ins leben gerufen
ministerpräsident mario draghi
bezeichnet diesen ort als ein symbol für
den schmerz einer ganzen nation
es ist auch der ort einer feierlichen
verpflichtung die wir heute eingehen
wir sind hier um unseren ältesten zu
versprechen dass es nicht mehr passieren
wird das zerbrechliche menschen nicht
angemessen betreut und geschützt werden
italien erinnert heute auch an die
selbstlosen helfer die ärzte
pflegekräfte und seelsorger die bei
ihrem einsatz ums leben kamen und dann
sind da fragen die nicht weggehen nach
versäumnissen im gesundheitswesen und
nach verantwortung von politischen
entscheidungsträgern und
pflegeheimbetreiber die angehörigen
fordern rechenschaft
ein jahr danach wehen die flaggen
landesweit auf halbmast italien steht am
beginn einer dritten welle mit einer
neuen impfstoffen sie will die regierung
dagegen steuern damit sich bergamo nicht
wiederholt ganz anderes thema die usa
verschärfen ihren ton in sachen nord
stream 2 und fordern den bau der gas
pipeline zwischen russland und
deutschland sofort zu stoppen
sonst drohten sanktionen
us-außenminister blinken wegen nord
stream 2 hatte washington unter
ex-präsident ramp bereits sanktionen
gegen den russischen betreiber eines
verleger schiffes verhängt die usa
befürchten eine große abhängigkeit
europas von russland die niederlande
haben gewählt ergebnis das parlament ist
zersplittert wie nie trotzdem steuert
premier mark rutte auf seine vierte
amtszeit zu seine konservativ liberale
partei hat gewonnen und wird wohl das
bündnis mit den gestärkten
linksliberalen fortsetzen
dafür brauchen sie aber noch weitere
koalitionspartner bei voraussichtlich 17
parteien in einem parlament das
insgesamt deutlich nach rechts gerückt
ist
tja und nun zum sport und zur
fußball-champions-league naja arbeit und
da sind nach den dortmundern auch die
bayern eine runde weiter münchen gewann
auch das achtelfinalrückspiel gegen
lazio der fcb steht jetzt zum
neunzehnten mal im viertelfinale der
königsklasse
das hat bislang kein anderer verein
geschafft hansi flick knackt weiter
rekorde mit gewohnter hilfe von robert
lewandowski gestern traf der
weltfussballer per elfmeter nachdem der
sk im strafraum gefoult worden war
in der zweiten halbzeit bediente aller
bei den gerade eingewechselten schoko
moting auch der ersatzmann erfolgreicher
suche in dem minuten in denen indem ich
zum zug komme gas zu geben zu helfen und
am besten natürlich mit dem tor
die souveränen bayern fing sich aber
wieder einen gegentreffer durch parolo
ein der dem überragenden josua kimmig
nicht schmeckte werden schon gern noch
zu null gespielt das ist uns zu selten
gelungen in die saison ein 2 2
1-arbeitssieg morgen wird das
viertelfinale ausgelost
bundestrainer joachim löw kann in den
beiden anstehenden wm
qualifikationsspielen in duisburg auf
seine england legionäre um ilkay
gündogan zurückgreifen laut zuständigen
gesundheitsamt dürfen die spieler
einreisen
für sie gelten aber noch strengere krone
auflagen so dürfen sie etwa außer im
spiel und beim training keinen kontakt
zu anderen personen haben zwei wochen
nach der leichtathletik hallen em in
polen ist die zahl der korona fälle bei
den teilnehmern auf über 50 gestiegen
auch das deutsche teams betroffen eine
halle 700 athleten aus 47 ländern noch
sicherer geht es nicht hatten sie
unmittelbar nach der em geglaubt mehr
noch wir haben gezeigt was in zeiten
einer pandemie möglich ist triumphierte
der veranstalter doch sie haben sich
geirrt sieben positive fälle vermeldet
der deutsche verband aufgrund von
nachkontrollen nach der rückreise und
wir hatten im vorfeld an unseren
bundesstützpunkten mit den umfassenden
ideen konzepten und auch im rahmen der
wettkämpfe der lesen mit unserem
athleten keine nachgewiesenen fällen
corona fälle mittlerweile in vielen
ländern deren leichtathleten in turin
waren hier 10.15 turun ein sportevent in
der halle wird zum hotspot schlechte
nachrichten für olympia in tokio wo
viele sportarten in der halle
stattfinden
das war so wie banken arbeitet er
winterliche aussichten kommen gleich von
katja horneffer schnee und schneeregen
schauer erwarten uns morgen das war es
von uns claus kleber erwartet sie heute
etwas später um 21 55 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen um 7 wieder zu
stellen bis dahin einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut
[Musik]
meine damen und herren in den letzten
tagen hat es ja kräftig geschneit vor
allen dingen in den alpen aber auch am
alpenrand morgen fallen die meisten
schneefall aber er hier in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen
heute gab es ja wieder kräftige schauer
zum einen waren dass regen und schnee
regenschauer besonders im südosten aber
auch häufig schneeschauer und wie die
genau ziehen kann kein mensch
vorhersagen da trifft so ein
regenschauer vielleicht dresden komplett
chemnitz ag bekommt einen
schneeregenschauer nicht ab und heute
nach gibt es weitere schnee und
schneeregen schauer sie sollten sich auf
gefährlich glatte straßen einstellen
im norden ist es dagegen zum teil klar
da bildet sich auch mal nebel und die
temperaturen sinken meist auf werte
zwischen +2 grad hier auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und minus vier
grad in der lüneburger heide am
alpenrand über schnee geht sogar bis
minus 7 grad runter und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen in der osthälfte
meist bei null bis fünf grad im westen
wird es mit fünf bis neun grad etwas
milder und morgens ihn wieder schnee und
schneeregen wolken über uns hinweg und
kräftigsten schneit es im erzgebirge im
oberpfälzer und im bayerischen wald ganz
anders siehts westlich des rheins aus
aber auch an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee da zeigt sich häufiger die sonne
am samstag fällt am alpenrand noch etwas
schnee da es ist sehr kalt und
wechselhaft und wenig milder geht es
danach weiter schönen abend noch